on tuesday there was a ton of
liquidation in the market uh it
basically we were live when it happened
and uh the price fell from like 50 to 53
000 all the way down to 42 000 at one
point um and prior to that crash we had
futures open interest rising uh
alongside an uptick in the estimated
leverage ratio and so what that
basically meant was we just got super
over levered and then there was this
washout there was basically kind of a
de-levering that happened in the
derivatives market and that's why that
price movement down happened so quickly
and so if we look at that futures long
liquidation you can see that we were
really kind of building up and then you
just got this massive uh liquidations
and so i think at one point it ended up
being a couple billion dollars worth of
liquidations that happened across all
the various exchanges you can see that
that happened almost uh in step there
with the price
coming down as well so pretty clear on
chain to see
the long liquidations happening meaning
people were over levered long price
falls they get liquidated and it
accelerates a downward move in the price
next we've got the perpetual futures
open interest uh that was also wiped uh
and you can see this will basically say
that look this is like a healthy
cleansing uh especially when you get a
view of how inves investors acted
throughout the event but this future's
open interest in perpetuals again you
can see uh kind of a quick drop there in
september on the far right of the chart
i just kind of immediately just fell off
a cliff
and then lastly you can see the futures
estimated leverage ratio uh you can see
that we basically since july uh had been
kind of building up slowly there and
then all of a sudden got that big
wipeout or kind of that cleaning of
leverage in the system remember leverage
is not good or bad it's only good if it
go if the price of the asset moves in
the direction that you have leverage and
if the price moves against you then it
becomes very very big liability and so
obviously the people who had lots of
leverage on and were looking for bitcoin
to go up in price ended up getting wiped
out
then we've got the funding rates uh as
we can see here they were all rising
prior to the sell-off but we got the
first reset to negative funding on the
hourly scale since august so you can go
all the way back there you can see in
august we had a couple in the beginning
but pretty much that funding rate has
been uh positive um and then we just
went negative there again quick recovery
though which is a pretty healthy sign
but first time that's happened since
early august and then the market
absorbed about 262 million dollars of
net realized losses uh the first day of
net losses since august third so again
since the uh the beginning there you can
see uh right there uh kind of may june
july and into early august when the red
area that's where people were taking
losses basically they were selling uh
bitcoin or bitcoin was trading hands at
a loss from where it had been purchased
and then since august 3rd we pretty much
hadn't had any uh bitcoin trading hands
at a loss in a material way on a net
basis but
during that big crash obviously some
people were selling it as they got
liquidated at a loss that brings us to
soper if will was here he'd be giggling
to himself right now because every time
that we talk about we've been talking
about super for so many months that uh i
think people are tired of hearing us
talk about it uh but super is a measure
of the state of profit and loss that the
coins trade at on any given day um and
so on the top here we have the a
soprametric this excludes outputs less
than one hour uh so it kind of filters
out all the noise
and what you can see is that the sopra
keep that that number one right is kind
of that bar there you want to see that
every time we get close to it it bounces
off and recovers so we don't want to go
sub one uh and so you can see there uh
in september it basically bounced right
off of uh of this one super line
and continues to recover here and so
then if you start to look at some of
these other ones is every time that we
get any sort of bounce or retraction
whether it's short-term holders or
long-term holders on the bottom you can
see that right when we get around that
one there seems to be some pretty
significant resistance and then it'll
recover and so uh will calls out that
yeah this is really like a buying
opportunity a lot of times again
historically
we can look at the data it doesn't mean
that the future is predicted by the past
but every time that we get near that one
sopra tends to be a pretty good buying
opportunity because that we just bounce
right off of it and head backward back
upwards and so when you start to look at
the spent volume age bands
you can see is we're trying to identify
who is responsible for the majority of
selling on any given day um and you can
use this spent volume age band metric uh
it shows the percentage of spent volume
derived from each age bracket of market
participants
and similar to what we see in the
short-term holder sopra uh we also have
a large uptick in spending coming from
younger cohorts so basically people who
just bought the bitcoin they were
spending it uh and most of that is
because the liquidation cascade mixed
with some selling from younger coins
that's what caused that price drawdown
to be so severe and so quick when it
happened and so if we then go and we
look at the market structure we can look
at something like the supply shock
ratios we continue to look at this and
it continues to say the exact same thing
on the right here you can see the green
bands where back in april and into may
it was red right we were going down the
supply shock ratio was screaming on
chain telling us hey this is not healthy
this is actually bad likely to lead to a
price decrease what you can see is
starting in july
in august and then again now in
september we continue to have that
supply shock ratios move upwards um and
you can see that it's highlighted there
in green what that basically is telling
us is that it is likely to lead to a
supply shock which usually leads to a
price increase which is pretty
significant exchanges are down another
about 1.2 billion dollars this week
meaning that exchange it people buying
bitcoin and moving it off at the
exchanges and it's reflected by this
exchange shock supply ratio if we then
look at the whales uh whales continue to
increase their holdings again this past
week uh this metric uh that we've got
here takes into account all entities
with over a thousand bitcoin and then it
filters out any entities that
are on chains such as grayscale etfs
qbtc etc
and also all exchanges so it's basically
non-exchanges non-financial products
that have more than a thousand bitcoin
and so in total wales added about two
billion dollars to their wallets over
this past week so literally two billion
dollars worth of bitcoin was bought up
by people who already had at least a
thousand bitcoin in their wallet and so
whales continue to buy very very
aggressively especially when price
crashes they're just gobbling up all
that cheap bitcoin and so it's really
easy to get concerned by short-term
moves but will basically state that it's
important to remember the broader
picture is highly bullish
they have a long-term holder supply
shock ratio
and you can compare that
coins held by the long-term holders the
short-term holders and what you see is
that the ratio is now approaching a zone
that has historically caused a supply
shock effect in the market caused by
long-term investors locking up
substantial portions of bitcoin again
we've been talking about this for weeks
now but it's continuing to play out over
the next few months the metric will have
reached the upper bound of this ss range
if its trajectory continues the amount
of supply in nominal bitcoin terms
continues to reach all-time highs
increasing by about 3.82 billion dollars
this week so this isn't solely long-term
holders buying coins this week a lot of
it is short-term holders aging past the
155-day threshold that then makes them
long-term holders but also long-term
holders are buying as well and so it's
very clear here you can see that
whenever we have gotten up into uh kind
of that green area there usually is
pretty significant price movement that
follows shortly and so you can see all
the way back to july of 15 we then got
that massive 2017 bull run we then saw
in january the kind of the second half
of 2018 into 19 uh in the bottom of the
bear market we then got a price run and
then again in uh kind of the middle of
2020 again we started to see that supply
shock ratio entering into the green zone
we then got a big price movement up
again pass doesn't predict the future
but we just now are entering into this
green area now it would not be
surprising to see a massive move upward
because the supply shock ratio kicks off
kind of rocket fuel for bitcoin and then
lastly as we have the miners uh if we
take a peek at what they're doing the
hash continues to come back on the
network very aggressively it's showing
no signs of slowing down as more
competition for the same block reward
comes online the minor revenue in
bitcoin per hash has dropped obviously
more people competing for the same
reward each person makes less but when
denominating it in us dollar terms their
revenue looks very strong and it's
because the bitcoin price continues to
increase and so miners are making less
bitcoin but more in dollar terms because
the price of bitcoin goes up and so
miners continue to sell off although
nothing substantial they've sold an
additional 467 bitcoin this week
according to class note
you got to give a shout out to will even
when will's not here he's dropping he's
dropping knowledge
that was a lot of knowledge right that
was too much knowledge so basically in
summary the way that this works is uh
there's bitcoin that's sitting out there
in circulation wales bought about 2
billion worth of bitcoin the exchanges
had about 1.8 billion almost 2 billion
of bitcoin that was purchased and then
taken off of the exchange we continue to
see the hoarding of bitcoin which is
increasing that supply shock ratio as
bitcoin circulating supply becomes more
and more illiquid when new demand shows
up to the market there's less and less
bitcoin for them to buy as demand
increases and the supply of an asset is
being more constricted the price has to
go up to accommodate everyone now that's
predicated on the fact that people keep
buying bitcoin and holding an illiquid
and strong long-term hands and it's also
predicated on the fact that demand will
continue to increase for bitcoin so as
long as those two things happen which
are basically increases and
continuations of the trends that are
already underway it is likely to lead to
a very very fun second half of the year
things could change do not take this as
investment advice but watching the
on-chain metrics is fascinating because
it basically gives us insight into what
potentially could be happening in the
future what's up guys bang bang thanks
so much for watching the best business
show today if we're going to be the best
business show we obviously need the best
partner that's why the exclusive sponsor
the best business show is sofi they're
an all-in-one platform that allows you
to invest in all kinds of different
assets including stocks etfs crypto ipos
and they even have an automated
investing function if that's your thing
so before we start getting after it
again make sure that you go download
sofi you get an invest account and when
you make your first crypto trade
regardless of what you buy they'll give
you 10 in bitcoin for free it's that
simple head on over to sofi.com to get
started today thanks so much for
watching and i hope you come back and
watch more of the best business show
tomorrow
[Music]